you could fit six of my biceps him your
biceps it's a bee sting it's incredible
yeah yeah you weren't just work out
constantly right I say yes it's not at
all so genetic Factory in fact everyone
in Australia looks like this yes I know
I've noticed that I have walked around I
walked around Sydney once and people
were just doing hands you know chin-ups
and handstands and yeah I'm why most of
my garages shut up like of gyms right
just working out just working out and
and if I'm if I'm not in the garage I'm
in the living room just with the kids
just pressing the kids the good health
that's good I think if you have to give
a good attitude now let's talk about
this you grow up three brothers I grew
up with brothers we fight constantly
yeah I mean as kids kids we would just
wrestle and fight and hit each other and
I'm thinking about first of all you're
both of your younger brothers are taller
than you is is that a first for that one
thank you thank you for that much anger
you that's fine I don't think about a
rule yeah same but how does you guys
fight you must have fought all the
threes kids I mean we do i oh you do now
still we still do look we you know when
Chris and I grew up it was off at each
other all day long every single day and
then Liam came along and we're both like
hey did
we're like truce yeah let's beat him up
yes and I ended up sitting in the middle
and they'd fight across me and then I'd
stop it and then like it still goes up
and today up up until this point because
as adults you fight each other well we
had we had Saint Patrick's Day a few
weeks ago I don't even know when it was
that yeah the Irish ah yeah months ago
yeah and me me and we ended up wrestling
for about two hours straight and I
remember I remember my wife's face I am
in a headlock and he was kind of getting
a bit blue and that means you've cut off
his oxygen yeah
he's sad he's pretty smart he watch the
holy breath he was sad because he was
losing yeah but my wife my poor wife was
I she was like really really yeah I was
still doing this yeah and my wife my my
mom she she walks up and she she shakes
her head cuz she's been so saturated by
over the years right now this male
energy you guys fighting all the time
yeah yeah and she cheated usually walks
by and says awful Ian yeah puts the boot
in yeah what a wonderful relationship
don't we mother what a wonderful woman
bidding for st. Patrick's Day though
sling fighting yeah yeah yeah yeah we
were there was no snakes but it's what
our people do
you